why just number 6 of 18 pushed half and  the pass deflected but a foul is called  and draymond Green irate and I believe  he's gonna talk yes he's been injected  Tyler's Ford  giving the signal  and that's it for Greymon picked up a  second technical which is automatic  ejection as he tripped Dwight Howard  well you knew that the way draymond went  at the official on the first occasion  that it was gonna be tough for him not  to pick up a second you know the  interesting part when Jay mom was  walking off the bench the coaching staff  was looking at the scores she just kind  of let him walk by after he walked off  as a guy that's his dream I'm not happy  with not getting a call that time on the  white Howard  so draymond returns after missing two  games walk alone LeBron kinda enjoyed it  right here he's turned to hide behind  and  laughs he said he's going on he's gonna  get it I tried to pop back like he  didn't do anything